kreiert für das einzig wahre team cup
und alle die sich richtig krass kennwort
berlin lebt also das design finde ich
bin ich gut hier einfach hans soße und
creme fraiche und hier aber so ein
marihuana bleibt drauf also da muss ich
sagen da werden wir die pizza doch um
noch einiges sympathische und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja weil
ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut heute
haben wir wirklich sehr interessantes
vor
eigentlich wollte ich das video nicht
machen weil nuri meinte er die pizza ist
safe überall ausverkauft das mich kurz
hinsetzen und ich werde dann sowieso
einkaufen und dann habe ich im edeka
eine pizza gefunden gut der
titelrechnung gelesen es geht um die
neue kapital burger pizza in gemüse
indischen und salami edition ich bleibe
euch schon mal ganz kurz meinen einkauf
ein ist nicht lang aber nur ganz kurz
fachleute jetzt war ich gerade hier bei
edeka haben endlich mal eine von diesen
pizzen gefunden aber nur diese grüne
also die gab es dann auch ordentlich
dieser lahm ja weg der mann ist hier nur
diese pizza grillgemüse aber die ist
ordentlich dicken also das ist schon
irgendwie muss ich sagen ja keine ahnung
wir fahren am 22
vielleicht haben die nämlich noch eine
andere bezirke mich dieses salami dinge
dass wir auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
bis gleich genau wir hatten erst mal nur
diese pizza das war die einzige die es
im edeka noch gab also nee drei waren
noch übrig habe eine genommen dann
dachte ich schon so ok wahrscheinlich
ist diese salami variante überall
ausverkauft dann war ich noch im rewe
und die hatten wir ganz schöne menge
deswegen haben wir hier noch die salami
variante ich muss sagen tiefkühlpizza an
sich ja klar macht man sich auch ab und
zu mal eine tiefkühlpizza feiere ich
jetzt im großen und ganzen aber nicht so
krass ab da mache ich mir lieber eine
frische pizza mit frischen zutaten aber
wenn es mal schnell gehen muss warum
nicht wir testen ihr euch mal ich bin
vor allem auf die sich hier sehr
gespannt ja wir haben hier eine
vegetarische pizza team cup grillgemüse
also was nicht direkt mal sagen muss ich
feiere das design eigentlich sogar das
ist wirklich mein design nicht so wie
bei diesen youtuber pizzen oder bei
diesen youtuber produkten das ist immer
so langweilig kann man das design da hat
sich wirklich wahr was bei gedacht na
schön so als pizza koch drauf dann
stehen ja so ein paar sachen
wie macht einen auf krank ist innen aber
barca ist halt für die jugend
wahrscheinlich ne
die feiern sind was beweist auch
irgendwo ist lustig als plastik unten
smiley auf dem ich sag mal so ich habe
ja sonst auch noch nie irgendwie so ein
produkt von dem youtube oder eben was
getestet also kapital brauche ist jetzt
der erste läufer dessen produkt ich
testen
wir machen einfach direkt mal auf ich
bin echt gespannt weil die ist so ein
bisschen dicker als andere pizzen das
merkt man so ein dreck
fangen wir mal hier an wenn der
grillgemüse indischen das ist alles
drauf paprika spinat zucchini tomaten
und mozzarella also die riecht
eigentlich schon nach so muss ich sagen
deshalb ziemlich viel draus gemacht also
das ist schon viel belag wenn ich mal
gespannt vielleicht wird mir das zu viel
seien aber an sich erste eindruck ist
nicht schlecht also wir haben die
paprika tomaten spinat zucchini körper
also eine zusage hat man wirklich nicht
das bad dann können wir hier weiter zur
pizza salami drei käsemix das finde ich
sehr gut ich mag der käse sehr sehr
lecker und da bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt wie dies merkt wobei sonne
salami führt erst mal nichts besonderes
keine ahnung tiefkühl salami pizza wie
auch schon gestern ausnahme von hier
irgendjemand stück oder so aber
vielleicht überzeugte mich darin dass
allawi hat sich auf jeden fall schon mal
sehr gut an billy lebt mit 100 rinder
salami übrigens die an beide 93 gekostet
ist schon nur ein also ist schon nicht
weh nicht so wie ich mir die auch schon
vorgestellt wird so ein bisschen
dickeren laden scheiben ja da muss ich
sagen finde ich diese hier ganz klar ein
bisschen leiser blass sieht bleibt
einfach ausgehen
salami pizza oder aber sieht aus wie
eine gute seele ja okay ich will das auf
jeden fall nicht schlecht dass dieser
ein bisschen dicker sandy plätze was ich
mich gerade auch noch gefragt habt von
welchem hersteller sind die denn ich
muss noch einen seiner vorlesen
die spezial edition pizza vom
ranghöchsten
kreiert für das einzig wahre team cup
und alle die sich richtig krass können
wolf berlin lebt also das design finde
ich wirklich gut da hat sich jemand was
bei gedacht und so soll es ja auch sein
damit der salami an weil die wird
wahrscheinlich aus wie eine salami pizza
wie die danach aussieht da bin ich mehr
drauf deswegen fahr' zur jungen pass auf
ich parallel werde jetzt mal hier im
ofen oder ofen leistungskurse highlights
auf 200 grad aber gibt es ja irgend eine
vorrichtung hierfür rheinbahn ist eine
tiefkühlpizza aber die haben immer auch
vorgang
naja egal jetzt verfassen für mich heißt
es abwarten für euch nicht wir sehen uns
sofort wieder bis gleich nein den
teilnahmen war grad und vergessen zu
erwähnen
hier steht einfach hans soße und creme
fraiche und hier aber so ein marihuana
blog drauf also da muss ich sagen da wir
die pizza doch um noch einiges
sympathische und die auch oder
also ich muss sagen sie schon gut
auskomme
ich weiß jetzt nicht also erst einen hut
oder was machst du klar ist mir stand
als salami pizza aber bevor wir das
probieren machen wir direkt mal hier die
kappe grillgemüse pizzeria andere pfizer
ist auch ein ofen ganz kurzer trick den
habe ich euch auch schon auf meinem tik
tok mitgeteilt dass auf jeden fall ab
alexis alex wir haben jetzt zwar die
sind ja schon verdammt schnell dreckig
gemacht aber wenn man mal kein teller
beschützen möchte ist das gar kein
problem
dann nehmen wir hier einen karton dieser
kartons eignet sich auch sehr gut dafür
kann reist man das hier so ein bisschen
auf andere seite einfach das wird dann
ganz bewusst sagt einmal hier und hier
und dann fallen wir das einmal unten
klicken das hier und jetzt haben wir
ganz perfekt um unseren pizza unterbot
sozusagen und an sich ist kein thema
geworden das sieht doch ich es doch eine
pizza viel lieber so schön hier von
diesem papier als von so einem teller
oder und wir brauchen nicht mehr
gesteckt denn ich kann dir einfach so
schneiden
ja ich weiss nicht also das riecht ganz
gut aber es ist halt so dieses typische
salami tiefkühlpizzen flair weise also
so ganz überzeugt bin ich halt nicht von
salami tiefkühlpizza aber kommen
der boden soll laut karton schön krank
sein aber trotzdem baba ob das so ist
testmails markiert aber gern noch ein
bisschen mehr käse auf der pizza gehabt
oder kann man hier fehlt zum beispiel
ein bisschen was aber sonst auf jeden
fall vom aussehen her sehr gut let's go
[Musik]
also schmeckt halt wie eine ganz normale
salami pizza schmeckt so schlecht
braucht mich jetzt auch nicht um kann
ich sagen war so mit dem hintergedanken
dass sich salami pizza eigentlich nicht
zur feier ist die nice kann ich
empfehlen kann man auf jeden fall gut
essen
aber es hat sich so mein persönlicher
mag deswegen freue ich mich viel mehr
auf die grillgemüse wird ja weil ich
glaube die wir schon ein bisschen besser
wunden mit schweizer probieren danke du
würdest du das uns aufgeht mit osram
text noch nicht sogleich in die kamera
aus ist reif ist hierzu das weiß ich
doch fällt also heute wir sehen uns
gleich wieder okay leute hier haben wir
da jetzt auch die grillgemüse pizza ich
muss sagen gefällt mir auf den ersten
eindruck schon viel besser als die
salami pizza die richter also direkt
wirklich sehr gut die richter sogar
gesund richtig auf jeden fall was man
auch direkt ist deutlich mehr käse drauf
was sich sehr sehr gut finde und
ansonsten keine ahnung was wir noch
eingefallen ist
ich glaube es gibt auch keine pizza auf
dem markt die bis jetzt so in diese
richtung geht also nur mit grillgemüse
drauf oder oder bist du da anders
informiert sicher wenn ich mir nicht auf
jeden fall habe ich noch nie so eine
probierte deswegen bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt ob die mit überzeugt wir haben
hier ja auch diese grüne hand so drauf
das sieht man glaube ich auch ganz gut
hier oder wenn ich mal sehr gespannt wie
die hand so schmeckt weiß jetzt aber mal
rein ist noch sehr heiß
[Musik]
also wir sicher dass frankreich mag ein
bisschen schmeckt man dieses cremig
freistoß die hand so sie schmeckten hans
lose oder was ist da drin also das den
geschmack an die nicht zu orten ich weiß
nur einmal noch viel rein weil wir sind
ein bisschen mehr verschiedene
gemüsesorten auf einem fleck also ich
finde ich auf jeden fall deut besser als
die salami pizza wahrscheinlich auch in
meinem persönlichen geschmack aber auch
so generell wirtschaft wie mir die suppe
zu empfehlen aber einer muss ich noch
einen weißen hier oben haben die spinat
inhalt auf der pizza muss man will habe
ich das gehasst jetzt finde ich sogar
neckar ließ erklären und also möglich
ist ein solches wirklich gute budgets
kann ich diese kann ich euch wirklich
empfehlen holt euch die mal probiert
immer ansonsten würde ich sagen ich habe
noch eine sache die ich am ende kurz los
werden muss wir schicken dir mal kurz
zur seite
ich habe ja letztens in einem video zum
ersten mal weg zu meinen eigenen burger
gemachten kastenberger einfach oben
drauf und der decke das sieht doch aus
wie in ein auto oder es geht halt besser
aus als in vielen bürger leben halt
wirklich vom aussehen haben die schon
mal auf der karte
es ist so dass ich habe niemals gesagt
von burger stelle war und seitdem
versuche mich immer ein bisschen zu
steigern und ich habe mir gedacht ich
will einfach mal so eine art liefern ins
mache also ich mache meine eigenen
bürger ihr könnt diese stellen bei mir
auf instagram wenn ihr aus der nähe von
köln kommt ich mache euch die und bringt
ihr euch vorbei komme ich aus dem
fenster story sondern speisekarte die
design ich mit drei verschiedenen burger
variant da könnt ihr euch eine aussuchen
schiffen eurer adresse ich mache auch
die liefert die ihr könnt sie probieren
und schreibt mir dann wenn corona
schreibt mir dann auch ihr euch
geschmeckt hat oder halt nicht deswegen
wenn ihr aus der nähe von köln kommt
also wirklich können nicht nähe von köln
wenn ihr aus köln kommend und bog darauf
habt dann schreibt mir bei instagram
oder wartefrist sich diese speisekarte
der post meldet euch dann dafür und dann
wird das ein geiles video da freue ich
mich drauf wie viele leute können
wachsen drei pro video 3 ich kann ja
nicht den ganzen tag durch können dieses
zuschauern abonniert auf jeden fall alle
meinen
kanal alexander gibt es jeden tag ein
video und wir sehen uns am freitag
wieder um 19 uhr gibt's neues video
aber hier den kanal ins taxi und checkt
gern die plätze ab vor allem die grill
gemäss polizei ist sehr sehr nice haut
rein